robotic surgery is not yet standard in
Germany but it's routine in the US the
surgeon controls the robotic arm with a
computer and uses 3d glasses to see
where to precisely place the sutures the
director of the Institute for robotics
and mechatronics believes this
technology will soon become common in
Europe if chador inside that they're not
before in the cluster just like in
conventional operations the surgeon
decides where and what to cut but he now
has a tool in his hands that's much more
precise it can enlarge or minimize his
movements and filter out shakey
movements that way the movements become
much more exact and that makes the
operation more precise but also more
expensive this surgical robot currently
costs one and a half million euros but
the price is already falling just ahead
of its official launch
it's expected to be especially helpful
for prostate and appendix operations
medical technology is one of the fastest
growing industries this robot sterilizes
and sorts surgical instruments that
saves personnel costs in hospitals but
dr. Alva Schaefer does not believe it
will eliminate jobs he may die by the
disease even the workers who have to do
these monotonous tasks who spend eight
hours a day sorting the same surgical
instruments will of course be overjoyed
to be able to do other jobs through the
Niemen at the University of Bielefeld
scientists are testing the humanoid
robot now which helps teach languages to
children four-year-old tim oh' is
learning english now it's your turn what
color is the block the robot does not
replace a teacher but only functions as
an important adjunct to a human
instructor a technical system like this
is of course incredibly patient it
explains something for the hundredth
time just as kindly as it did the first
time if we consider language training of
migrant children of course the teachers
here in Germany
may not necessarily speak the child's
mother tongue but we will soon be able
to give the robot the ability to speak
to them in their mother tongue so next
question come now won't just teach the
kids we'll also be able to play with him
but it will take some work to give him
the ability to keep up with child's play